[Music]
why does this fight scene work so well
is it because the underdogs come out on
top or because before the fight they
used to be friends well not really there
are three things that make up a good
superhero fight effective cinematography
audience investment and the right level
of realism and in this video we're gonna
talk about these three aspects of
superhero fights as well as how this
fight scene from captain america civil
war checks off all the boxes first
things first though we have to talk
about cinematography
[Music]
one thing a lot of superhero movies get
wrong during fight scenes is the
cinematography whether it be because of
an unnecessary shaky cam
incomprehensible flying fights or just
bad choreography a lot of big budget
superhero films fail to meet the mark
take the shaky cam technique for example
in some cases it can be used to
perfection such as in the church fight
scene and kingsman the secret service it
can help lend a sense that everything is
out of control in a frenzied craze or
like many scenes in the jason bourne
franchise it can make scenes almost
impossible to watch a lot of times it
seems shaky cam is simply used to cover
up poorly choreographed fight scenes
compare this scene from 2014's john wick
to this one from 2007's born ultimatum
in one we have a highly stylized brutal
fight sequence where it's hard to miss a
beat and the other we see rapid cuts and
a screen shaking so badly it's difficult
to see what's even happening
it's not too hard to tell that john wick
displays the epitome of what fight
scenes should look like and you can find
echoes of the techniques used in john
wick in several superhero fight scenes
tools such as shaky cam are just that
tools they can be used correctly or
incorrectly depending on the scene in
the film in which they're used another
issue that comes up a lot in regard to
superhero fight cinematography is the
infamous flying fight scene you know the
scene where two seemingly invincible
characters fly around bursting through
skyscrapers shooting lasers out of their
eyes at one another where it seems as if
nothing is ever really accomplished
these scenes can be painful to watch and
a lot of this comes from the fact that
we can't tell if any of what they're
going through is painful for them we can
only feel their pain when they're more
grounded and i mean that literally for
instance we can't tell if it hurts when
superman is flying through a building
with concrete falling down on his head
but we can certainly tell when iron man
sucker punches captain america that that
hurt when the heroes finally find
themselves on the ground that's when we
start to actually see what's happening
and can feel the weight behind some of
the hits that land in most flying fight
scenes it's hard to tell what's going on
and it starts to feel like unnecessary
fluff just there to make the run time a
bit longer when the fights come to the
ground though it's more likely that
we'll be able to feel what the
characters feel and it gets us more
invested in their struggles which brings
us to our next topic audience investment
you can typically tell when an audience
is invested in a fight scene if they
wince when a big blow is landed or when
a bone is broken on screen take this
scene from the dark knight rises when
bane slams bruce down on his knee the
audience cringes when they hear his
bones crack
now why is this why do we care when
christian bale's batman gets hurt but
less so when ben affleck's batman gets
hit it's because we're invested in
christian bale's version of batman it's
because we care about the outcome of his
fight and we want to know who wins but
how exactly does a film get an audience
invested in its characters well they
could establish a narrative across a
cinematic universe spanning over a
decade to get the audience invested like
we saw in avengers end game or they
could just give us sympathetic
characters with somewhat relatable
stories like we saw in captain america
civil war movies have to get their
audience invested in the characters to
make satisfying fight scenes an instance
where this certainly wasn't the case was
in the final fight scene in batman vs
superman i really doubt anyone walked
out of the movie saying they thought
that fight exceeded their expectations
the reason a lot of these scenes fail to
get us invested is because they lack
high stakes and by high stakes i don't
mean something like the end of the world
i simply mean that there has to be
something in jeopardy that's important
to the characters for us to care about
the outcome of the fight and again this
doesn't have to be something like a bomb
dropping on a major city or a giant
about to rip itself out of the earth's
core it can be something as simple as a
man trying to protect his best friend i
think this kind of grounded approach to
finding the right stakes for a given
situation is essential and it's rooted
in the film's level of realism over the
past decade we've seen superhero movies
try to create stories that feel more and
more realistic with varying levels of
success the thought is that older
superhero movies are too far-fetched for
people to believe in and care about the
heroes so creators have tried to make
their films as realistic as possible
while still trying to make us believe
that the characters in their films can
fly and lift cars above their heads
while this thought has some merit it
should be taken with a grain of salt one
of the reasons why so many people love
superhero movies is because they grant
us a sense of escapism and they allow us
to suspend our disbelief for a couple of
hours while we watch people and tights
beat each other up it's this suspension
of disbelief that makes superhero movies
superhero movies without it we'd be left
with no caped crusaders and no friendly
neighborhood bug heroes finding the
right level of realism for a superhero
movie can be hard though let's take the
character of batman for example in some
cases the realism in batman movies can
go too far like with 2016's batman vs
superman or not far enough like with
1997's batman and robin and others
though they can get it just right like
we saw in 2022's the batman this film
finds the perfect balance between
realism and escapism and a franchise
where it's rarely been found before the
batman gives us a realistic and
believable character while also allowing
us to suspend our disbelief and escape
our world into the dark gritty
underworld of gotham city very few
superhero stories have been able to find
this balance and it's difficult to make
a good superhero fight without it
however there are a few exceptions to
this rule for instance the tv show
invincible finds itself very low on the
realism spectrum but it's still able to
give us some amazing fight sequences
because we're invested in the characters
because we receive some stunning
animation and fight choreography and
simply because of the pure shock and awe
its scenes present on the opposite end
of the realism spectrum though we can
find the tv show the boys which also
gives us some incredible fight scenes
even in its hyper-realistic environment
again this is because of audience
investment great choreography and
cinematography and the show's fresh take
on the superhero genre i believe that
the best superhero fight scenes though
are the ones that do all of this they
use great cinematography they have a
high level of audience investment and
they find the right balance of realism
one of the best examples of this can be
found in the fight between captain
america and iron man in 2016's captain
america civil war this scene works so
well for several reasons for starters it
uses incredible choreography and camera
work to show us all of the action at
once as well as the limitations of the
characters in the space where they're
fighting it doesn't really rely on shaky
cam because it would be unnecessary in a
scene such as this instead we get
somewhat long takes that allow us to
feel some of the weight behind the blows
being landed and it makes us care about
the outcome of the fight because we're
concerned about the characters on both
sides we feel sorry for tony and
empathize with his desire for revenge
but we also understand steve's need to
save his friend bucky's life most of all
though this scene finds the perfect
balance of realism it's not completely
one-sided and tony doesn't just
immediately win with his super-powered
armor we see a fierce battle between
equals where their lives are all truly
on the line and yes it has a satisfying
ending because the underdog comes out on
top but it leaves us wanting further
resolution because these characters who
have been friends for years are now
separating themselves after such an
intense fight while there are tons of
examples of great superhero fight scenes
there are probably more not so great
ones out there for these fights to
really land with the audience creators
should look to iron man and caps fight
as a case study on how to use effective
cinematography get their audience
invested and find the right level of
realism now i'm sure there are more
aspects of superhero fights that can
make them great so leave your thoughts
in the comment section below also check
out the video on your screen for some
different content don't forget to like
and subscribe and thanks for watching
rocket riley